we're just two weeks away from the
presidential election a lot of the
undecided swing states have come into
focus those states could once again be
the deciding factor in who wins the
presidency so I've asked around an
erector for his analysis on the state's
it will play a pivotal part in this
election where do you got for Sandy oh
I've got plenty Konan let's go to the
map
[Applause]
well
all right something got real up there
[Applause]
[Music]
so we said I mean the election actually
say we shall we start that again they're
gonna start that again I just can't I
don't know what went wrong there we have
what I'm not saying we have a
professional show but when something
just doesn't happen right
that is bone-chilling yeah yeah all
right let's try that again and through
the magic of editing you won't see me
say how tough this show
[Applause]
wow you guys are good that was crazy
that was insane thank you alright bla
bla anyway election election election
please we can't do that whole speech
again
what's everyone on tonight so I mess
around Andy Richter for his analysis on
the states that will play a pivotal part
in this election what have you got for
us Andy
Conan I've got plenty let's go to the
big map
[Applause]
get me out of there back any time Andy
see you later
[Applause]
you